قال رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان عدد
ضحايا الزلزال تجاوز ثمانيه الاف وخمسمائه
شخص فيما تجاوز عدد الجرحى 49 الفا اضافه
الى انهيار نحو سته الاف وخمسمائه منزل
واضاف اردوغان خلال زياره تفقديه لمدينه
كهرمان مراش ان الدوله تبذل قصار جهدها
لتخفيف اثار الزلزال
نواجه كارثه كبرى كان الشعب التركي اظهر
صبرا كبيرا في كوارث شبيهه وهو يظهر صبرا
كبيرا على هذه الكارثه ايضا الدوله تبذل
كل ما في وسعها لتخفيف اثار الكارثه ويعمل
الوزراء يدا بيد مع مسؤول المؤسسات
والبلديات
الرئيس التركي واكد ان الدوله نسقت مع
فنادق سياحيه في مدن عده لواء المتضررين
من الزلزال كما وعد الرئيس التركي بتوزيع
انابيب غاز على المواطنين داخل خيامهم
وكما فعلت مديريه الاسكان الجماعي مسبقا
فان المديريه ستبني منازل دائمه للمتضررين
خلال عام كما نسخنا مع الفنادق الموجوده
في انطاليا الانيا ومارسين وغيرها لايواء
المتضررين مؤقتا الدوله مستعده لتامين
جميع مستلزمات المواطنين في الفنادق من
ماكل ومشرب وماوى وغير ذلك مراكز التنسيق
الموجوده في المحافظات العشر مستعده
للتنسيق لنقل المواطنين علما ان انتقالهم
الى هذه الفنادق سيسهل على الدوله اعمال
الانقاذ والاعمال اللوجستيه الاخرى